welcome to bananamores give it up
for one of my favorite alliterations
j jourdan hello
hey happy black history month
yeah i know it's not february but i
didn't come up with a stereotype
also if you celebrated black history
month i want to
thank you if you did not celebrate black
history month you might
want to change the channel like right
now
you might even want to turn the tv off
but i have bad news when you turn the tv
off the screen
will still be black i'm very happy to be
here i feel like i've come
full circle this time last year i was on
tv
and this year i am on my boyfriend's
last
nerve no kidding i'm on tv i'm on
daytime tv i'm very happy
to be a guy on daytime tv and not have
to worry about
a paternity test this is nice i'm
a millennial don't get too excited it's
just a fancy word for 30.
yeah i'm a millennial and people used to
make fun of us they used to say oh i'm
sick of these millennials
in high school millennials we aren't in
school we are
in debt we are in therapy we are in debt
because of
therapy or we're in therapy because of
the way that our debt makes us
feel i mean on the one hand we want to
be happy but in the other hand
we have our phones it's rough i don't
even like that term
millennial that's my generational cohort
it's because we grew up
during the millennium i don't know if i
like being named
after a backstreet boys album right i
don't know if
i want it that way and tell me why the
generations after us got such
cool nicknames you got gen z don't make
fun of me
you got gin alpha then gin omega because
that's when the world ends bye-bye
doesn't work and before us you had
generation
x and before them you had the baby
boomers and before them you had the
silent generation
which was named after the way that our
great grandparents had sex
just a whole lot of
was it good for you evelyn it was good
for me
i can make fun of older people because
the pandemic has turned me
into one i've definitely aged during the
pandemic
you can't tell because black don't crack
but it also
don't like being locked up i am at that
age where some of my friends
don't know their dads but also some of
my friends
don't know that they're that right i am
i'm old enough that i look pretty good
in
a robe that trap
like when you're 10 and you wear a robe
people say oh look at him he thinks he's
a grown-up when you're 20
and you wear a robe people say what frat
are you in at my age people see me in a
robe and they just say we will
keep the music down mr jordan we
understand it's late i'm like yeah it's
9 30.
that's a lot of promotion y'all are
keeping up i'm old enough
to use the word commotion correctly but
i'm not
old enough to enjoy baseball i'm not
there yet
the other day i could tell i was getting
older because i walked outside i saw a
group of kids
outside of my building and the first
thing i said was young man
what are you doing pull your mask up you
look ridiculous do you know what that
means in prison
no i like the kids i like the youths i
think they're doing a lot of stuff right
they know about all these different
activisms and
being socially aware they know about
intersectionality so if you don't know
intersectionality that's when you
hook up with someone at a four-way stop
the intersectionality
that is when you are more than one thing
at once like me i'm black and i'm queer
or as the previous administration called
it two strikes maybe i do
like baseball but being black and queer
it's interesting because it means that
sometimes when white women see me they
instinctively clutch their purse
but they have to compliment mine
thank you mj jourdain wow
the wowza wowza that jay jordan
knows how to work a crowd